hello everybody bandit here today i
wanted to watch some old zelda
commercials because
it's been about two years just about two
years since we've had some zelda news
from nintendo but since we know there's
going to be some breath of the wild 2
news confirmed coming later this year
it just got me thinking about all the
possibilities of what we might see
come e3 time or whenever nintendo's
deciding to
talk to us about set game so i figured
hey let's watch some of these
older zelda commercials and just kind of
reminisce so strap in we're about to get
super nostalgic
up in here and i am never going to say
that again oh also before we get into it
i just wanted to let you know that just
about 80 percent of everybody who
watches my videos is actually not
subscribed if you have been watching for
a while and you do end up enjoying my
videos or this video in particular
please consider subscribing to the
channel just takes a really quick
really quick click and you can always
unsubscribe if i lose my touch
so let's start off going all the way
back all the way back to the nes
okay here we go uploaded by uh zelda
dungeon this is the first commercial for
the legend of zelda on the nes
here we just see the latest nintendo
newsletter whoa wow this was going
with that hands on that game you mean
you haven't played it yet
we can play it on my nintendo
entertainment system it's the legend of
zelda and it's really rad those
creatures from kiss
are pretty bad please don't move like
that buddy
yeah go link yeah awesome
intense the nintendo entertainment
system i should have known i should have
known uh
so it doesn't say when in the
description but this was uploaded in the
80s when that was
the huge stereotype about gamers they
were either the intense type with the
jackets and the hair or they were the
nerdy type i think he pushed his glasses
up like 12 times
there he is right there in the preview
he's pushing his glasses up he's sitting
there dancing along he's like gotta put
my glasses back up
the legend of zelda oh man how far we've
come if anything how far we've
come in resolution okay so this right
here is the snes commercial that was
released in japan for a link to the past
um i do think i've seen this one before
a long time ago i think this is the
dancing one
if i'm not mistaken we're gonna go ahead
and play it here i think this is the
dancing one oh crap
i'm gonna try to not hit my mic yep
yep i knew it yep
it's been too long
oh man i mean you've got to admire the
sheer skill
we've got uh lizard thor
i'm sorry wait was that supposed to be
her talking
apparently she's gone through a couple
voice actors over the years but let's
keep going
[Music]
oh there we go there's that theme
[Music]
yeah get him link chop that statue's
head off
[Music]
oh but it's not over
never looked better buddy oh ganon
go go go go oh and we've got a little
snippet of ganon at the end there
okay that that was just fabulous i don't
know why any of you would laugh at that
all that was was professional and
fabulous i'd
nothing else to say about it except for
zelda's voice don't know what was going
on there also i am
curious to see like what the uh
conversation looked like between
nintendo and
whoever choreographed this entire thing
was probably pretty interesting but
moving on so i have actually never seen
a commercial for links awakening so this
is going to be
oh it's a puppet
i'm sorry
i'm sorry did lake just die for a split
second there okay i had to come back
here and pause it because um yeah they
really did just show link dying on
screen
you're just gonna show that on live tv
nintendo link dead on screen
for all the kids that want this game
times used to be so violent man
i mean one thing that i can say though
is that this essentially recaps the
entire opening of link's awakening
anyway so they should have just put this
in the game
although i can understand why they
didn't because excuse me if they would
have put this in the game
uh people might have returned the game
right after so a little bit of wisdom
that nintendo had there
okay now we're getting into my childhood
here we got the ocarina of time
commercial i was extremely extremely
young i'm talking like super baby status
when ocarina of time came out
so i don't remember any of the
commercials necessarily
but it is weird to think that this is
what you know tv looked like when i was
a
a wee babe and by weird i mean it's
depressing to think about it
a dark time is approaching
ooh love the use of slow-mo
we'll still run or fly
love the music oh man if anybody could
even tell what was going on
must now sink or swim
love it oh this track is amazing
[Music]
don't die crying uh trying sorry can't
read anything on this
toaster quality here
i'm pretty sure this is worse in the end
so opens now suck
[Music]
oh man and then those graphics at the
end coming november 23rd
have you what it takes okay pretty sure
that one still holds up today
you can play that just in hd quality and
uh boom you're selling the game in fact
they should have just redone that one in
hd when the 3d remake came out don't
know why they didn't that would've been
smart
nintendo you should call me for these
decisions all right what came out next
oh yeah majora's mask okay this person
apparently got it in like
somewhat widescreen okay that's not
widescreen but it's
better video quality maybe no it's not
never mind i take it back
i've never seen this
[Music]
oh are they gonna they're gonna do the
moon aren't they
where is this kid playing is he being
watched i'm sorry what was that scenario
right there
seems a little freaky to me yeah it's
the moon
yeah what's going on with that kid
playing it in like a
freaking scientific study room layer
type thing
and then somebody playing it like in the
streets
you know what's funny about this is that
these
real life 72 hours is nice
[Music]
i don't know why it was rated e for
everyone but what's funny about all of
this is that
these people in this commercial for the
game react like
way more than anybody in the game does
when the moon is actually crashing on
them it's just funny
but yeah i really like that commercial
actually it was dreary it wasn't really
funny
if i saw this when i was a kid i would
definitely be
afraid wind waker commercial here we go
oh
man i think i remember this one oh the
nostalgia okay i'll shut up one second
that echoes a legend a legend
held dearly by the royal family
they really went up with their cg in
this one who became a man
he embarked on a great journey
that was some skillful gameplay right
there
[Music]
testing the
[Music]
which is above all else
to save me
oh oh i just got goosebumps
i just got goosebumps from that that was
beautiful don't know how i feel about
that whisper at the end there
don't really want whispers in my ears
that was gorgeous okay
but it's kind of funny uh people's
number one complaint about wind waker at
least like
in my experience like my own siblings
for instance they didn't want to play
wind waker because it looked
like that you know link had this big old
bible hey oh look this is like a beta
version like that's not how
the ui actually looked uh ended up
looking in the game excuse me a lot of
people didn't want to play it because of
that and i feel like that's why they
went all super dreary with like the
actual irl portion of the commercial
to try to like loot people into it who
previously were like
whoa ocarina of time would stop fight or
will stuff fly you know like oh man i'm
gonna fight i ain't gonna fly
and then right after that they had
majora's mask which was like moon kill
people
and now you know it's like bobble heads
so yeah i feel like this commercial was
for those people who were expecting a
more
serious version of the legend of zelda
and i think when i was a kid i thought
this was zelda
right here saying to save me according
to the lore
of which i am resident expert on the
channel
also the only person on the channel but
according to lore this should be
link's sister errol aryl however her
name is pronounced because technically
that's why link does anything in the
wind wakers to save
his little sister which actually kind of
makes it hit home a little bit more
now i think about it the two styles
going back and forth was a little
jarring but i really liked this
commercial all right what was next
twilight princess i remember these
twilight princess commercials so
hopefully this will also
just like hit me right in the nostalgia
oh this the track oh my gosh i loved
this so much
i actually this is a little quiet let me
try to turn this up
i actually learned this on the piano no
joke
somebody had um composed it
oh my gosh
and this was when they had all the
feedback about the cartoon style of wind
waker
and they decided to go realistic style
and boy did they knock it out of the
park
i remember when this was the most
realistic thing i had ever seen
and it was so mature so dark
man i remember this
[Music]
oh midna's old hair
[Music]
holy cow i don't remember that
oh this music was so good this music
could sell the game alone
oh and the emotions save him link
horseback battling
oh my goodness
i mean this trailer covered at all side
characters you can be in a canoe
link's got some weird farmer clothing
horseback riding
giant spiders
man creepy puppets
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean that was the best commercial so
far i don't think anybody would disagree
the the epicosity of of zelda trailers
just
skyrocketed through the roof with this
and yeah like more than half of it is
probably
because of the soundtrack but oh my gosh
i mean it covered everything you know
who this is because of the silhouette
with link here
although in the game of course this
entire animation was redone he doesn't
even have
the um the armor at this point in the
game if i remember correctly it's been a
little bit since i've played
unfortunately
but they put this in the trailer so that
you know okay this is link you know the
silhouette he's turning into a wolf
he got this weird little evil looking
imp creature who's going to help you on
your quest
this last shot right here of course they
needed the logo but i wish they had
ended it with
the shot right after this fight where
link is just like on horseback
like raising his sword in the air
i may have to go play twilight princess
after this i i may have to okay moving
on coming up on the end here's skyward
sword commercial
all right i think we're officially in
the like 16 by nine ratio full screen
commercial era so
cool i don't remember this one
i'm sorry that just fall past a plane oh
hello
this seems mildly dangerous mildly
dangerous
no i'm sorry buddy i wouldn't
he do you know how many people would be
murdered at this point
[Music]
okay we're just gonna you know that
aside
master the sword of the battle
and embark on the most epic zelda
adventure yet
do you remember the sword
the legend of zelda skyward sword only
on we
i liked that commercial for the most
part besides the fact that like there
would be
so many dead people it's not even funny
but okay yeah unfortunately that just
didn't grip as many people because
skyward sword really didn't sell that
well but i'm hoping that's going to
change this summer
hoping that's going to change fingers
crossed double crosses
wait that might cancel it out one
crosses alright guys here we are
so to be honest with you there aren't
really any commercials for breath of the
wild there's like tv spots
but they're normally just like trailers
that you know presented at e3 and stuff
like that so
i'm gonna go to this uh super bowl
commercial that i've never seen
and let's just kind of check it out all
right here we go
all right all right points imagine
dragon you got some points is this a
breath of the wild trailer or a switch
trailer
i suppose it's both oh this played at
the super bowl like at the super bowl
okay well then this was a big deal no
wonder they were trying to sell the
switch as well yeah i guess breath of
the wild didn't really get a commercial
like a full-fledged like one minute just
about breath of the wild like ocarina of
style twilight princess style skyward
sword style commercial but as far as the
super bowl spot goes i mean
this was good like i said i feel like
this was much more a commercial for the
nintendo switch than it was for breath
of the wild but hey i mean it worked
breath wild is the best selling zelda
game of all time i actually talk about
that a lot in my
recent video you should totally check it
out if you haven't seen it yet but now i
think that's
it we have just gone through 35 years
worth of zelda commercials obviously not
every single one of them and i skipped a
few games in between there but that was
just because i didn't want this video to
be like an hour long we sure have come a
long way as a franchise
and i feel like we have really really
really good things to look forward to
this summer if you think about it they
said that there's breath of wild 2 news
coming later this year
and they just came out and said they
have a huge direct coming at e3
so i'm thinking it's probably going to
happen at e3
so here's to hoping and here's to you
guys for watching if you want to stick
around for a lot of nintendo content
that i'll be uploading here
in the months to come up until e3 and
onward please make sure that you are
subscribed to the channel and leave a
like on this video if you enjoyed
the ride once again this is
massentinabandit signing off
and hoping you have a wonderful rest of
your day
[Music]
you